Tesla CEO Elon Musk is the subject of a
new controversy after he appeared to
smoke marijuana during a podcast
interview musk was a guest on the Joe
Rogan experience Thursday and on Friday
Tesla's stock also took a hit plunging
more than 6% to 263 dollars per share
Meg Oliver has more on Tesla's ongoing
struggles Meg good morning good morning
Rogen's interview with musk was in
California where recreational marijuana
use is legal but this is one of many PR
troubles for Elon Musk in Tesla the
company's debt was downgraded to junk
status in March by Moody's Investors
Service musk even joked that company was
bankrupt in a tweet on April Fool's Day
it all makes you wonder if Tesla could
go up in smoke tobacco and marijuana in
there that's all it is smoking what
podcast host Joe Rogan said was a
marijuana and tobacco joint is just the
newest controversy for a new on musk
who's Tesla company is mired in a
federal investigation and faces
shareholder lawsuits
that's after Musk tweeted he was
considering taking the company private
last month a move that boosted Tesla
stock prices at the time CBS this
morning co-anchor Gayle King spoke with
musk in April I'm definitely under
stress so if I seem like an under stress
then I'm gonna be clear I definitely
under stress he said Tesla was going
through production hell but he felt
positive about its future I'm feeling
pretty optimistic about where Tesla is
at this point I can have a clearer
understanding of the path out of hell
but the feeling may not be mutual Tesla
lost more than 700 million dollars in
the second quarter this year and after
Musk's appearance on the Joe Rogan
experience
Tesla's stock plunged before closing at
its lowest price since March 2017 dr.
Howard Combs is a professor at the San
Jose State Lucas College of Business
he said Musk's behavior could smoke out
more investors but if they believe
you've lost the magic touch and you
really are kind of stumbling out
gate now and not really sure where
you're going they will punish you and
punish you severely Tesla also saw a
string of high-profile departures this
week on Friday its chief accounting
officer David Morton left after working
there for just one month who's max Jeff
Gann covers technology for Bloomberg
Businessweek last month he told us musk
was becoming a distraction from the work
Tesla does he's always been you know
somebody who works very hard but but it
really feels like he's reached you know
some kind of you know breaking point
Tesla has only a few weeks left to
deliver on Musk's promise that the
company would post sustained profits
during the third quarter in an interview
with the New York Times last month musk
said quote this past year has been the
most difficult and painful year of my
career it was excruciating it's no ease
amiksak holders aren't comfortable when
the CEO is telling you he's under a lot
of stress right and the chief accounting
officer resigning after a month right
and remember max saying earlier that
they were they were just worried his
family was just worried about him that's
never a good sign
yeah well it's not all right Meg Oliver
thanks Meg